this is the Jocko podcast Civil War
Excursion number one with JD Baker and
me Jocko willink good evening JD good
evening Jaco
B January 21st 1861.
I Rise Mr President for the purpose of
announcing to the Senate that I have
satisfactory evidence that the state of
Mississippi by a solemn ordinance of her
people in convention assembled has
declared her separation from the United
States
under these circumstances of course my
functions are terminated here
it has seemed to me proper however that
I should appear in the Senate to
announce that fact to my associates and
I will say but very little more the
occasion does not invite me to go into
argument and my physical condition would
not permit me to do so if it were
otherwise
and yet it seems to become me to say
something on the part of the state I
hear represent on an occasion so solemn
as this
it is known to Senators who have served
with me here that I have for many years
advocated as an essential attribute of
State sovereignty the right of a state
to secede from the Union
therefore if I had not believed there
was a justifiable cause if I had thought
that Mississippi was acting without
sufficient provocation or without
existing necessity I should still under
my theory of the government because of
my allegiance to the state of which I am
a citizen have been bound by her action
I however may be permitted to say that I
do think she has a justifiable cause and
I approve of her act
I conferred with her people before the
Act was taken counseled them that if the
state of things which they apprehended
should exist when the convention met
they should take the action which they
have now adopted
Mr President and Senators having made
the announcement
which the occasion seemed to me to
require
it only remains to me to bid you a final
a year
I'm not right there is a speech
from Jefferson Davis to United States
Senate announcing the secession of
Mississippi from the United States a few
weeks later February 10th
Jefferson Davis was unanimously elected
president of the provincial government
of the U the Confederate States of
America
and this would lead to Civil War this
would lead to the downfall of the
economy this would lead to the
destruction of
people's lives of families and it would
lead to the wounding and death of
Millions
and it would rip us under the United
States of America
but it would in time
free the slaves
and allow America to live up to our
ideal
that all men are created equal
but it was a wretched Road
and it's a road that we should not
forget we walked down
let's talk about how we got there let's
talk about the two men leading these two
Nations
the opponents
Abraham Lincoln
and Jefferson Davis
JD let's talk about Jefferson Davis
uh yeah uh if you look at uh Jefferson
Davis uh he's born in Kentucky and then
again he was raised down in Mississippi
uh Jefferson Davis uh he was a West
Point guy uh you know went to West Point
graduated up there uh he fought and at
the time if you went to West Point
you were
an aristocrat basically is that is that
a safe assumption or is that too strong
no no that that's a pretty good yeah he
uh Jefferson Davis was like the the
youngest of 10 kids okay so that's no
Aristocrat yeah uh well no no but like
his his oldest brother was a very
prominent lawyer okay so he had
connections you know because you gotta
you got to get an appointment uh you
know to be able to get in so yeah it's
to achieve an appointment uh to West
Point
that's a that's a pretty fair feat I
would say it's probably still difficult
today to to get into you know West Point
or any of the The Academy Schools of of
achieving you know a congressional
appointment to get in so
um you know they're Plantation folks you
know what I mean that he was born up in
Kentucky but they moved down to
Mississippi they're they're running uh
plantations farming uh kind of thing
it's a big family uh you know back then
you know having large families you
needed to have a whole bunch of kids
because you got a whole bunch of work to
do you know what I mean that's you know
see you got those folks coming in so uh
it gets an appointment uh up to West
Point uh you know it goes up to uh
up to New York
uh you know he fights in the in the in
the Mexican-American War uh and he
actually fights underneath his
father-in-law uh his first wife I
married into the Zachary Taylor family
uh which you know so and Zachary Taylor
uh very prominent Virginian uh you know
marrying into that kind of family uh
that that's that's a pretty big deal uh
you know marrying in uh if you want to
look at it of like who you marry into
like Robert E Lee married into the
Washington family so it's kind of like
NASCAR uh you know what I mean like JD's
not getting in because my last name's
not Petty or Earnhardt or Gordon uh you
know what I mean so there's certain
pedigree uh that that does come with
that uh but he fights with distinction
uh and underneath uh with him he uh
he then goes runs an office uh he's
Secretary of War at one point in time
again he's down every other appointment
after the initial election that he wins
uh in the congressional seat he's
appointed uh after that so he wins one
time uh but you know Jefferson Davis uh
growing up uh in Mississippi Plantation
owner he is very much pro-slavery
uh and voices his opinion uh for slavery
for states rights uh he voices his
opinion for you know you got the
territories uh that are that are pushing
out on western expansion of the Manifest
Destiny kind of uh which was the whole
uh aspect of you know pushing everything
West the United States see the shining
sea kind of thing he was huge with
Manifest Destiny and he was also huge
with the expansion of slavery into the
territories and that's and that's a
critical kind of political debate at the
time we got these new territories that
are coming online
and the people in the north primarily
are saying look we can't have slavery in
these new areas and the people in the
South are saying no we need to have
slavery that's a bunch of Farmland that
we're taking over so this is a a real
key kind of political debate at the time
is is slavery going to be allowed in
these new territories right yeah it's uh
yeah it's a it's a huge debate and you
know who controls the house is important
so you know who is a free state uh who's
a slave state you know what I mean
because when you go in for voting to
sway with inside the Senate that's going
to be huge but you know I mean the uh
the debate you know if you look at it in
the in the time frame of like you know
of right now when you know you just read
from from Davis you look at it in 1860 I
mean we're pretty young
country I I would venture to say that
we're still a pretty young country
um
you know when uh you're talking about
four score uh you know what I mean of of
the Gettysburg Address I mean you're
kind of dating for you know a score for
the folks that don't know it's 20 years
uh so you know it's four scores so 80
years ago you know what I mean we just
had you know like England over here
running around we got fed up with that
[__] so we were like hey let's you know
let's let's have a war of independence
uh and then we get we get done with the
war of independence so we're going to
get like rid of this you know this this
hierarchy of the king and queen we're
going to be the United States of America
and you know the home of the free you
know and and next thing you know like we
we find gold in North Georgia and so
let's come up with an Indian Removal Act
uh because the Indians had that land at
the time yeah you know if you went to
North Georgia you know what I mean you
got the the Choctaw Chickasaw Cherokee
they're all running down there well hey
man they got gold so what do we do is we
the people of the United States let's
have an Indian Removal Act why not you
know I mean put them on a flat boat take
them up to Chattanooga Tennessee dump
them off and then hike them out to the
Oklahoma territory it's going to be the
new Indian Territory and we're going to
take the land that they're there so uh
even you know prior to the slavery issue
of really being a thing of like what
we're kind of talking about you had like
the liberal north of like you know Henry
David Thoreau of Civil Disobedience you
know what I mean of like uh calling for
you know all machines have their
friction but when friction has its own
machine you need that machine no longer
meaning we need to overthrow the federal
government like who are we like we're
literally creating this machine that we
just overthrew like like just a few
years back and now we're removing people
we're enslaving people you know what I
mean for work so a lot of the liberal
North uh are actually as well calling
for the overthrow of the government
they're not happy with the United States
government uh and then you know coming
into the expansion of after the
Mexican-American War you know I mean
there's a lot of contention when you
kind of look at the Mexican-American War
we go down we pick a fight with them and
it's like okay we'll take you know part
of Texas and then kind of hang it right
let's just snag New Mexico Arizona you
know let's take California while we're
at it uh you know what I mean and those
folks in Mexico I mean they had just got
their independence from Spain you know
what I mean and they're like okay now we
got these dudes coming in so there's a
lot of turmoil in the United States it's
a very young country of what what
direction are we gonna are we gonna go
yeah you can see it's like a startup
almost like a startup company that's
just growing so fast there's no there's
no uh particular course that we all know
we're on and this is where we're going
it's like a startup's like there's
opportunities gonna pop up we're gonna
move in this Direction moving that
direction there's it's it's the the
future is not clear no and and who are
we gonna base it off of like if you look
at historically yeah you know what I
mean because you got to look at like
okay so how do we run this with the the
We the People kind of thing you know I
mean even at the very beginning uh you
know what I mean after the war of
independence you know some of the
officers hadn't gotten paid for their
time uh and up in Newburgh New York you
know all the officers get together and
they're like hey we're going to have
this like secret meeting up there in New
York and we're gonna we're gonna
overthrow the government that we
literally just created and we're gonna
make King George the first you know what
I mean because of course George
Washington he is the most popular guy
obviously uh and so they're gonna happen
well you know so George gets wind of
this little you know meeting that's
going to take place amongst the officers
and how they're going to come in and
make him like King George at the first
and you know and he comes up and he you
know he he mounts the stage and of
course everybody quells he's a very he's
got a very uh prominent uh dominant uh
uh command presence and he he pulls out
his his his spectacles
and they called him spectacles back then
because you look like a spectacle with
them on your face uh you know and it's a
sign of weakness you know showing
weakness in front of your subordinates
kind of thing and he's like my eyes have
grown blind to the service of my country
you know what I mean so he's showing
that you know what I mean yes and the
service
of my country you know I mean we're
gonna have to have some sacrifices here
look I I get it man we haven't gotten
paid we're gonna get that we're a new
country we're trying I mean we're
literally trying to figure stuff out
well I mean you get in through the
Indian Removal like it's still just this
this project that we're kind of throwing
together like you said with a new
startup company I mean so we're going to
start up a new country we got to figure
out what kind of rules we're going to
play by
um so you know Jefferson Davis with this
expansion that's kind of coming in
of course he's an advocate for for
slavery uh you look at the Confederacy
of the Confederate States I mean they're
solely based on agrarian culture it's a
it's an ingredient and they need people
to work
uh and
and why why why did Jefferson Davis rise
to prominence why did he get this
powerful position of getting elected as
the president of Confederate States
just I mean is it just the culmination
of everything you just said this guy's
he's got money he's been in government
before he's been in the military and he
was just the most prominent guy suitable
for this job yeah and as you read I mean
he's very well spoken he's very well
listened to and again you know back in
back in the day even even uh still to
this day uh you know I mean you serve
the military with distinction I mean
you're what's in the newspapers you're
you know there's no uh there's no
Twitter Instagram and stuff like that
for people to be able to follow so
everybody's reading newspapers and and
these guys are the ones that are front
page in the news uh so he he's the voice
so he's got this following of of
individuals uh and you know when he he's
you know at the democratic convention uh
because you know we had kind of
chit-chatted before you know like back
then in like 1860 I'm pretty sure there
was there was four different tickets uh
that you could kind of run on uh for a
for the president of the United States
so so four different political parties
to say yeah yeah and two were Democrat
because the Democrats they split so you
had Northern Democrats and you had the
southern Democrats and then you got this
Republican party that's gonna come in
because you know like in history
probably read about like the wigs the
Copperheads I mean they have all these
different names and stuff like you know
in in 2022 we know Republicans Democrat
and dependent well they had you know
they had four more of them uh back then
and of course with the southern
Democrats
um you know they were you know western
expansion pro-slavery uh you know see
the shining sea they're all for that uh
and the folks that are when they're
they're looking at this secession from
the union not along with Alabama
Mississippi South Carolina you know
there's other states that are kind of
teetering of are we going to secede from
the union and Jefferson Davis is the
most outspoken so it's like unanimous
down in Montgomery Alabama they're
they're going to pronounce him as the as
the President of the Confederate States
uh and the first White House of the
Confederacy is in Montgomery Alabama
still stands this day it's about a block
and a half
from the actual capital of Alabama and
you know what I find interesting is uh
the street that it's on is Washington
Street
first president of the United States
yeah so there's a little bit of thought
process behind there now on on the other
side
um
for the union we kind of I don't want to
paint this to be too much of a I don't
want to exaggerate this but you have a
little bit of the antithesis of
Jefferson Davis in Lincoln who
you know he's he's not uh
professionally educated right so you
know Davis went to West Point
Lincoln is just self-taught for the most
part
um he seems like he's more of a working
class guy than Davis is that an accurate
assessment yeah uh I mean they even had
like back then like you know we kind of
chatted a little bit you know when they
called in like the rail splitter you
know what I mean he was like a blue
collar you know what I mean raised you
know born in Kentucky uh you know he's
he's got a PhD it's called a plain high
school diploma you know what I mean I
got one too uh but he read a lot you
know what I mean so you know I look at
it education's been free since the
establishment of the first Library get a
library card read uh you know what I
mean and that's what Lincoln does and he
moves out with the family out into
Illinois and you know what I mean it's
just you know and he starts to read he's
he's not formally educated
um but he starts working he gets jobs he
starts making his way up and then he's
gonna run and run for office uh and he's
gonna walk and go and he's he's a big
guy uh you know for back then
uh he might even still be today one of
the tallest presidents at the time he
was over six foot
um but you know and he lost his first
election trying to run you know in the
state of Illinois but he was persistent
uh and he was always trying to
continually continue his education uh
continually be smarter meet with more
people uh study law uh you know that was
kind of a big thing back then uh working
in inside law uh and then you know so he
is definitely an opposite of of Davis
you know what I mean he's not getting
that formal education he doesn't have
the military background uh basically
like Lincoln you know what I mean like
did some paperwork for a couple of weeks
during like the Blackhawk Wars or
something and hey check the box got the
military kind of thing going but he
doesn't have like he didn't fight in the
Mexican-American War you know what I
mean of like uh folks are gonna take
that distinction against him
um so then he's you know going to decide
on the Republican you know he's going to
become a Republican and then he's going
to try to run on the Republican ticket
um and there's a lot of other folks that
are that are inside of there but again
you've got to kind of uh you know if
you're looking at the at the four
different factions of the of the
political parties that are in there
there's actually a great book uh written
by Doris Kearns Goodwin called uh Team
of Rivals
uh and it's it's how like Lincoln you
know what I mean plans out how he's
going to run for president
uh on with each one of those parties
there so he's he's literally going to
try to go into it is to be number two in
each one of those four parties now don't
go for number one
you know what I mean so if he can be
number two in each one his total scores
eight
but if you're like number one with the
Republican party but then like you're
number three and number four and number
two with the other ones one night you
got a twelve you lost you know what I
mean so the strategy uh behind Lincoln
um and then you know you kind of got to
look at it as obviously uh
you know coming into it is is the
expansion of slavery into the
territories uh everybody's got to run on
kind of a party line of like what
they're gonna you know what they're
gonna do uh inside their presidency kind
of thing and you know Jefferson Davis
marries into a very prominent
Taylor family
uh
Abraham Lincoln marries a woman and her
whole side of the family is pro-slavery
so I mean that that's going to make
Thanksgiving a little awkward
you know what I mean of of discussions
uh yeah I mean you kind of look at you
know in in today's society of you know I
mean of of what side of the fence you
ride on or you know your political or
true I mean could you imagine you know
back then I mean you know you're looking
at some of the folks of what side of the
line you stand on uh you know
pro-slavery anti-slavery the expansion I
mean there's going to be America
in the 1860s it's just I mean it's it's
coming to a boiling point but it's not
you know I think the misconception is
everybody thinks that okay Abraham
Lincoln gets voted in and half the
country leaves well okay yeah that's
true but there was a lot of years of
build up to get to the Civil War uh
and you know and it is the greatest
catastrophe
that has ever happened in this country
uh of what took place uh coming in in
1860 and yeah when you look at the at
the party systems you know Jefferson
Davis was a single soul I mean there's
it's a one party
well that's kind of odd yeah you know
what I mean I mean we have one party
countries that exist today uh they're
called tyrannies
um you know but uh for for Jefferson
Davis uh you know and he's going to
become the president and he's going to
stay the president of the Confederate
States throughout the entire Civil War
like you know like we always talk like
you know when we when when you and I uh
chit chatting we're talking about uh you
know Abraham Lincoln and you know you
read in the Gettysburg Address while
we're up at Gettysburg and all that kind
of stuff I mean he's got a re-election
coming in 64. I mean you never hear
about re-election uh taking place you
know like like Davis has got to worry
about a re-election uh coming in it's
just he got elected
yeah uh which is kind of odd uh so you
know when you look at the at the
differences uh of the two
um you know it's it's it's very it's
very interesting and and uh
uh in those aspects of one is
self-educated one's formally educated
one's got the military background and uh
how they're gonna run their
administrations kind of completely
different and one of them's kind of blue
collar and the other one's kind of an
aristocrat yeah is that an accurate
assessment because it seems that way to
me looking at it yeah I mean like
Lincoln doesn't own anybody
in fact Davis owns people yeah uh he's
got a plantation you know what I mean
it's uh so yeah I mean he's they're on
they're on different levels like Abraham
Lincoln's not banging it at the Country
Club Davis is you know what I mean he's
got like box seats the football games at
the at the Running Rebels down there
Abraham Lincoln he's not even invited to
the football game check
uh as we look at the North and the South
and kind of set them up there's a great
um
great great bit of writing uh from
Sherman who was General Sherman who's a
West pointer from Ohio he ends up
becoming the first superintendent of
what became LSU
originally called the Louisiana Seminary
of learning and so 1861 southern states
are starting to leave leave the union
uh Sherman resigns as the superintendent
of this school and and that's before
Louisiana secedes but he ends up writing
this letter
to another professor that he works with
a young Professor at the University and
this is just such a
it's almost scary
how well he understood things and how
well he understood what was about to
happen
and
it's just uh it's amazing to read so
here we go this is the letter from
Sherman he says you people of the South
don't know what you are doing
this country will be drenched in Blood
and God only knows how it will end
it is all a fault it is all Folly
Madness a crime against civilization you
people speak so lightly of War you don't
know what you're talking about war is a
terrible thing
you mistake too the people of the North
they are a Peaceable people but an
Earnest people and they will fight too
they are not going to let this country
be destroyed without a mighty effort to
save it
besides where are your men and
appliances of War to contend against
them
the north can make a steam engine
locomotive or Railway car
ly a yard of cloth or pair of shoes can
you make
you are rushing into war with one of the
most powerful ingeniously mechanical and
determined people on earth right at your
doors you are bound to fail
only in your spirit and determination
are you prepared for war
in all else you are totally unprepared
with a bad cause to start with
at first you will make Headway
but your limited resources
will begin to fail shut out from the
markets of Europe as you will be your
cause will begin to wane
if your people will but stop and think
they must see
in the end that you will surely fail
that's that's that's prophecy of what's
going to happen
yeah and the funny thing is is he's the
one that's going to lead the Army that's
going to do it uh you know what I mean
uh right across there so yeah his you
know his his foresight of vision uh into
the future and yeah that's a pretty good
pulse for a guy to have on on a nation
as a whole of you know I mean we're
building steam engines in the north you
got to take your cotton and ship it over
to Europe to make cloth and they send
you it back you know you might have the
will but you don't have the means kind
of aspect so yeah for for Sherman uh
yeah he's he's a he's an interesting guy
uh you know what I mean if you you kind
of pull the thread on on Sherman yeah I
was I was listening or oh yeah listen to
uh Thomas Soul book and he was pointing
out like you know cheese is from
Wisconsin
you know primarily think oh geez
Wisconsin why is that well it's because
they because cheese is really hard to
manufacture they got cows down south but
they weren't making cheese down there
it's the same thing you're saying like
they're taking they have the cotton
there in the South coming out of the
ground
but they gotta ship it over to Europe or
up north to make textiles out of it
it doesn't it's see it's crazy to think
that and meanwhile in the north they're
building freaking locomotives which is
like the equivalent of building a a
freaking jumbo jet right yeah and they
they're not able to make cloth down in
the South so it doesn't take much to
look at this from the outside you know
of course me sitting here in hindsight
2020 it's like hey no kidding but that's
CR that's a crazy it's a crazy uh Delta
between the two between a a part of the
country that can make
locomotives which means they can make
guns which means they can make cannons
which means they can make anything that
they need for War and the other part
can't really actually even make shoes to
put on the feet of their soldiers
um
you talked about the Indian Removal Act
what about what about
like uh the John Brown raid and how's
that how's that viewed
yeah well you know the whole That's The
Bleeding Kansas kind of thing you know
tell me explain to me more Bleeding
Kansas yeah Bleeding Kansas out okay
it's the western expansion it's slavery
uh John Brown is an advocate you know
what I mean he is not pro-slavery he's
anti-slavery uh he's gonna you know
demonstrations uh if you could imagine
you know having the uh what's the but
the moral courage
uh you know in that time in America to
stand up uh you know what I mean and go
against
um this thing that the country you know
I mean and for thousands of years I mean
slavery has been a huge part of the
world uh you know you conquer you
enslave you know I mean it's happened
you know through thousands of years uh
and then to to be one of the folks
that's out there that says yeah we're
just not going to do this anymore like
this just isn't right you know what I
mean owning another human being is just
not right uh so there's going to be a
lot of of events that are going to take
place you know throughout Kansas where
you know Missouri they're going to try
to this expansion coming in because of
course you've got some people that are
that are for it and you got some that
are against it so you know John Brown
starts making trips into what is now
like uh
Harper's Ferry Virginia it's now West
Virginia but back then it was Virginia
and right there on the Confluence of the
of the Shenandoah and the Potomac River
it sets out on a peninsula there's an
Armory there uh Man weapons and that
kind of thing that that sits there and
it's got a rail crosses right over into
Maryland uh and and he's going to Stage
a a raid on Harper's Ferry he wants to
take over this this arsenal of Harpers
Ferry and you know kind of get the word
out to some of the slaves and stuff in
and around the area like he's gonna and
then arm them and then we're gonna have
like this Uprising uh and he's going to
try it there you know the problem is
it's hard to get the word out plus then
you got to look at the Fear Factor
of like
of of being a Slave
and then you're going to want me to do
what you're going to want me to like
stand up and you're going to give me a
poll maybe with a little pointy stick of
a spear and a gun and we're going to go
against uh you know what I mean of this
um you know this slavery of a
demonstration I mean so there's a
there's a lot of Courage that has to
come in just to even stand up to take
part in something like that
and of course uh when you look at it uh
back in the day of the actual United
States uh military
um you know we don't really have the
military of what we would look at uh of
today
of what they actually had back then
um yeah cool yeah uh in 1860 in in the
United States time frame the Army
exceeding small uh and Scattered uh they
were unprepared to meet a secessional
crisis Army Appropriations for that year
were the smallest they had been since
1855. so if you're looking at by the
Numbers the end of the year return
showed that there was 16 367 officers
and Men on the rolls uh just over 14 000
of them were present for Duty uh of that
number 372 where line officers just five
of them were General officers and one of
them was Winfield Scott when you look at
the at the compromise of of the
companies 179 of were posted west of the
Mississippi of the 197 total so there
was only 18 companies on this side of
the of the of the Mississippi so when
John Brown does the raid
there's an individual that everybody
knows but more of General Robert E Lee
but he was Captain uh Robert E Lee of
the United States Army living over in
Arlington Virginia and he gets called in
and he takes a a company Marines from
the Navy Yard uh so you got Marines
because everybody else is out hold on
just slow down so you got
you got this this uh Rebellion is taking
place and this is going to be a
basically a rebellion against the United
States government because the United
States government at this time has
slavery and John Brown is anti-slavery
so he's gonna put together this raid
they're gonna go and get these weapons
hand them out to the slaves and it's
going to start a rebellion
now in order to quell this there's a
young Army Captain out of West Point
named Robert E Lee
and he doesn't have any Army troops is
that what's going on yeah they don't
they're there's nobody troops around
because there's only freaking 13 000
active Army troops in all of America
North and South
and there's some Marines in the Navy
Yard yep you know the uh you know back
then the Marine Corps job was basically
hanging out on the Navy ships to make
sure that there wasn't Mutiny they were
there to protect the captain of the ship
and and certain things so the only you
know uh ground combatant arms available
was a bunch of Marines so they snag up a
bunch of Marines and they send them over
and they ride the train coming out of DC
and uh when the Marines come in uh
there's also another young Lieutenant at
the time that you know is is from the
area his name's Jeb Stewart uh he kind
of comes up a little later on in the
Civil War of like I wonder why Robert E
Lee likes Jeb Stewart so much well they
got time together uh and the Marines
come in and and they end up uh in
Harpers Ferry John Brown they end up
taking over uh they get into one of the
engine houses that's up there uh so
they're basically uh it's in my opinion
the Marines come in and they're going to
do the first direct action a salt like
on this this uh this Firehouse this this
Engine House in Harpers Ferry uh you
know because John Brown it's his plan
isn't working out as well as he thought
it was going to uh and then you got
Robert E Lee coming in with a bunch of
Marines so he's going to try to Hole up
in this Engine House
and the Marines are going to come in
they're going to stack they got ladders
and stuff man they're going to create
entry they didn't have a breach at the
time but they're going to breach they're
gonna you know hooligan they're gonna
hooligan they're gonna make a hole
they're gonna make entry into it and
then they're gonna go to work on John
Brown and them and they end up quelling
uh the events taking place of the John
Brown raid at Harpers Ferry and then
they're going to take uh John Brown uh
and they're going to hang him in
Charlestown Virginia which is now
Charlestown West Virginia and some of
those northerner you know Henry David
Thoreau and some of those guys are
actually present at the hanging I mean
they're the the north is is getting
really upset uh with this whole slavery
uh thing that's going on uh in the South
so it's starting to get a lot of support
you know I I didn't talk to it earlier
but one of the other guys that was
running uh was governor Seward uh out of
the state of New York uh he's going to
end up being the Secretary of State
basically uh for Lincoln and the
administration uh and I can remember
reading about Seward and his wife took a
tour uh in the south
before the Civil War when she came back
she was like I will never again go back
to the southern states I mean she was
just
shocked at what she had seen that was
going on uh in some of the southern
states with slavery in America so you
know there was a lot of folks up in the
northeast of America to include Midwest
because you've got you know Wisconsin
Ohio Michigan uh you know you've got a
lot of these folks that are like this is
this is time you know what I mean we
need to you know over in Europe they had
already abolished slavery uh like wasn't
a thing I mean we were like one of the
last ones holding on uh and so it was
you know coming in and in the uh the the
civil disobedience in America uh this
was coming to a boiling point and John
Brown's gonna kind of chip that boiling
point but you still got to get the
American populations got to get in on it
um
and when Abraham Lincoln is elected
president of the United States yeah I
mean just like you had read I mean you
got like we're out it's it's on so you
got you know prior to this you've got
the liberal North that's calling for the
overthrow of the United States uh and
it's The Agrarian South that ends up
pulling the trigger
uh it gets us into you know what will be
the next yeah probably the five worst
years of American History is going to
take place uh with inside the Civil War
has the secession takes place there's
like people that have to it's almost
like a draft pick like an NFL draft pick
and then on top of that you got states
that some states that have to kind of
pick sides
what does that draft pick looks like you
got because the the Military Officers
come from West Point a lot of them come
from West Point not all of them but a
lot of them are coming from West Point
so these guys know each other you know
you and I did a podcast talking about
the camaraderie at the Naval Academy
where you you worked at the Naval
Academy for a few years these these
people they go through tough training
together they get educated together they
drink together they eat together they
play sports together they get educated
together so a lot of these a lot of
these prominent officers all were
educated in the same place in West Point
so now they're all trying to figure out
who's going where and who's going what
sides how's that wash out yeah I mean
it's it It's just sometimes it's
mind-boggling I couldn't imagine like
you know serving yeah it would be like
you know I mean the guys you served with
in ramadi and then you come back and
then the country splits and next thing
you know like some of them are on
different sides than you and you're like
wait a minute man like we shared in the
suffering together and now you're going
to be on the other side so yeah all
these guys are West points they're all
ring knockers
um and you know the first guy the
military basically the military advisor
to Abraham Lincoln uh is going to be
Winfield Scott well Winfield Scott's a
Virginian
so that that makes it kind of awkward uh
you know I mean Virginia is a slave
state he's a he's a Virginian uh and and
he's he controls all of the armies and
he's the advisor to Abraham Lincoln
field Scott at this time what's his
position he's uh he's basically like
he's the like the chairman of the joint
Chief or something he's the senior
military guy senior military guy he's
old at this point pretty old guy oh he's
right oh yeah he's an old guy like
65 70 years old yeah Winfield Scott yep
yep and and he's a Virginian he's a
Virginian but he's gonna he's gonna
stick it out with the Union he's going
to stick it out with the Union uh and he
had always you know I mean you know when
you look at that like a guy like
Winfield Scott you know I mean and with
anybody else like he's he's getting long
in the tooth and you know I mean he's
not firing on all eight cylinders
anymore you know what I mean it's not
like he's out getting after it you know
in the morning at five uh so he's kind
of earmarked and individual that you
know if if something goes down in the
United States like I got a guy who I'm
I'm gonna call and it's Robert E Lee
uh and he's right there in Arlington uh
he lives right Stone strobe from the
White House you know what I mean uh it's
What modern day today is Arlington
National Cemetery so Winfield Scott's
looking at all the guys that he knows
he's the senior military leader
and he's got his guy in his mind when
the time comes I'm gonna get my first
draft pick to save the union lead the
armies actually into combat because I'm
freaking too old for that so my first
draft pick is this guy Robert E Lee yep
yeah he's gonna call Bobby uh you know
and Robert he so he's he's gonna call
him up and yeah it's like one of those
uh uh points in time in history of like
you know I could imagine you know he
gets a note memo come over hey you need
to come see the chief staff of the army
of whatever uh and and he goes in and
he's like hey uh you know this whole
secession thing that's kind of going on
like I'm gonna need you to kind of stand
up and army man and go down and look
where you're gonna crush it
and he's like yeah I'm going with
Virginia
and turns and and and turns it down when
you read about Robert E Lee how hard was
that for him to make that decision was
this uh was there inner turmoil like oh
okay uh what can I do to preserve the
union or is he just like hey no we're
going I'm Virginian I'm out
I'm sure that he struggled uh you know
with the issue uh because you also have
to kind of look at it I mean and of
course you know all all histories
remembered history you know I mean of
what some guy remembered of another guy
remembered and then whatever Echo told
him then somebody wrote it down and now
it's in a book so we believe of what you
know I wasn't you know I wasn't there
but you know but of us I could speculate
to be like if if something happened in
the United States like right now you
know what I mean you know I'd probably
shoot you a tax be like hey dude what
side are you gonna go with
and you know what I mean you should
attacks over to Echo hey dude who are
you going to roll with you know what I
mean because
like we're all friends you know what I
mean I want to make sure that like I'm
not and then you're like yeah hey dude
I'm rolling with these guys I mean
there's there's a lot of these folks man
that are from Southern descent uh you
know they're they're fam I mean you know
Robert E Lee was I mean he courted his
wife in Fredericksburg Virginia uh right
across the Rappahannock River of George
Washington where he grew up as a child
uh if you look at mentorship of of
Robert E Lee he's he's a Virginian he's
a Washington
yeah you know what I mean he's he's he's
gonna stick with the Commonwealth of
Virginia but he's also kind of looking
at it of the aspects of who else is
going uh with the Confederacy
uh and if you're looking at it of kind
of who's staying uh with the North
um
so Robert E Lee uh he's going to come in
and I'm sure he he had to have struggled
because he served with a lot of these
guys in Mexico
uh so but you know I'm sure when he came
back uh afterwards as you can see like a
lot of other people like went and you
know they resigned their commissions and
they went to do other things that's why
the downsizing of the military after the
Mexican-American War they're like hey
yeah this is great but you know as a
country we're not going to stand up and
we're not going to have like this large
armies of what we have today or even
Navy uh on that token so you know but
Winfield Scott I'm sure it had a lot to
play in that he's a Virginian Robert E
Lee's a Virginian but Robert E Lee
served with distinction I mean it could
probably it's debatable but Robert E Lee
is probably
the number one graduate of West Point
like ever
I mean
he's he's
a pretty prominent guy uh and he's he's
married well uh into a family uh he's
living in Arlington Virginia got a nice
piece of property
um
and he's going to leave and it could be
underneath I'm sure it had nothing to do
with Winfield Scott it probably had more
to do with who's surprised the United
States uh when you look at it of who's
the president of the Confederacy well
it's Jefferson Davis where'd he go to
school he's a West pointer did he fight
in a Mexican-American war sure he did
you know he with distinction so do you
know that those two guys probably know
each other like really well and who does
he know this rail Splitter from Kentucky
that some prairie lawyer from Illinois
and you want me to like hang out with
that guy
um so I'm sure there had to be some
struggles I mean I imagine everybody's
struggling I mean you're going to see
this country of the United States with
just you know just you know not even a
generation of of folks you know what I
mean and we're already split
um
but you know to be able to to quell
these these forces so Winfield Scott's
going to call him in as the number one
draft pick and he's not going to get
he's not going to get that draft pick
um and then he's also you know you got
to look at the Navy side of it uh yeah
because you got to run a naval blockade
so where where do you go find Navy
people well well you know you just go
right down the road to Annapolis and you
got this place they call the United
States Naval Academy and you got the
first superintendent of the Naval
Academy uh Buchanan yeah we kind of
chit-chatted about that guy
and uh
you know when you when you go down there
of course he's the the choice to be the
chief of Naval operations for this this
new force that we're going to stand up
and it's not like we got a whole bunch
of boats but it's not big Navy uh at the
time so you got the Naval Academy you
got midshipman and he's going to be
offered the number one draft pick of the
Navy uh and he turns down and goes and
joins the Confederates joins the
Confederacy so we're the north is O for
two on primary draft picks out of the
gate
right out of the game right out of the
that's gotta be
because you know again you know you're
talking about the I'm going to text you
and you're gonna text that going kind of
like I'll see where we're going you just
get a mob mentality going that's got to
be nerve-wracking up north when the
first few people you're asking hey
you know are you in and they're like
nope
and then you got some states right that
have to make it so you got Maryland and
Delaware these are these are slave
states yep what
but they don't secede what's up with
that
uh well I mean they're they're under the
the you know and it's it's it's all
political uh you know what I mean if
you're if you're looking at the aspects
of let's let's take Maryland uh and then
you look at the aspects of okay so you
look at Washington DC and like literally
okay Virginia's gonna pop smoke and
they're gonna go south
what if Maryland goes we're gonna have
to displace this cool place we're
building called Washington DC because
we're going to be surrounded so
yeah with these folks are are not going
to succeed
to go with the Confederacy they're going
to stay with the Union but they're still
slave states
they have slavery uh in the states and
you know there there's a lot of look of
where you're bringing folks in uh if you
look at it economically I mean Baltimore
Maryland is a huge Port still is to this
day you know I mean I mean that's where
everybody around there that's in
Baltimore they make their money by
working something that has to do with
the port it's been that way forever and
but the rail line is going to come from
all your Northeastern states that are
going to run down you know through
Philly it's going to come down in and
through Baltimore to where now the folks
in Baltimore they're like hey man you
know we don't want these forces coming
from the north to quell the South
because it's going to take away our
livelihood
um
so before the vote kind of thing you
know you got Abraham Lincoln and he's
got his advisors and stuff and I can
imagine they're all sitting around the
table kind of like us and and they're
like hey so uh they're voting over in
Maryland tomorrow whether or not they're
going to succeed and everybody's like
yeah this this that could be bad if if
they decide to secede with
go with the Confederacy they're like
yeah so you know of course Abraham
Lincoln you know what I mean new guy
he's got to kind of look at it like what
do you think we should do there you know
he's talking like like his advisors you
know Winfield Scott and those guys
because you know Abe really doesn't know
I mean hell I wouldn't know he's only
been in the job a couple of weeks and I
hear half the country's leaving and now
I got Marilyn might have to displace I
like my house I just got my TMO move
just got in you know what I mean wife's
kind of happy got the kids checked into
school and so he's like well why don't
we just bombard the city of Annapolis
like what how about we just bombard it
then they can't vote
they're like Winfield Scott and them are
like yeah dude uh but when they do vote
they're definitely going to go he didn't
quite think of the hearts and Minds
playing yeah so Lincoln says hey we
should just bomb Annapolis let's just
bomb and then they just won't be able to
vote won't be able to vote
okay so they were able to remove that
idea from but let's be prepared
so he's like okay hey boss like yeah
like hey Jocko we can't bomb them okay
and then you're like okay well I want
you to be prepared so that if they come
out with that vote you know what I mean
and they succeed man we got we got
people in place to enact like
immediately because we gotta we gotta
keep Maryland in I mean if you're
looking at Washington DC and stuff like
that that's fine I mean it's almost as
if like yeah keep your slaves and stuff
just don't go with the Confederacy like
and it's a Maryland is a split State you
know what I mean like if you've ever
gone like you know Baltimore is very
different than the the western side over
towards like uh Sharpsburg Maryland uh
over towards that western side of
Maryland it's very it's Farm country you
know agrarian and then you go east and
then that's where you get like you know
Baltimore or Annapolis the boat School
the Eastern Shore I mean it's a very
different state so it's a split State I
mean there's some of the folks that are
like yeah hey dude we we need to roll
um and go with the Confederacy so I
always I always imagined that you know
what I mean so if I'm you know with the
with the state
and I'm coming in and JD's going to come
in and cast his vote that day and I come
you know skipping in and wearing my
docksiders got my little you know my
little boat boat shorts on and you know
I come in and I see you know Echoes
coming to vote that day too and I'm like
hey dude did you see those ships like
out there in the harbor and they're like
pulling guns at us man like what's up
with that it's like I don't know dude
but did you see the like they got an
army that's like like they're prepared
to do something
I think it's going to sway my vote
because I live in Annapolis
like
you know what I mean like that's going
to have an effect you know on me uh with
inside of Annapolis and then of course
you know you got the Naval Academy
that's like right there uh and you got
this guy yeah I was going to say of
which the superintendent's bailing he's
bailing you know what I mean he's going
south and you know how it is with
anybody else it's just like in any
sports if you get like this prominent
figure that moves to a team everybody
wants to go to that team yeah you know
what I mean so I'm sure that's going to
have like a huge effect on a lot of the
other Junior officers of where they're
going to want to go play
you know what I mean with with which
state uh and yeah I mean where are you
from is huge it even is still to this
day of like where you're born and raised
you know what I mean I mean that's
usually a big thing people are always
proud of me like you know Texas lord
they're they're happy is they're really
proud you know be a Texan you know what
I mean and there's just certain steps
back to life we respect you yeah oh yeah
of course yeah but Virginia you know
what I mean being from the Commonwealth
or from any state so there is that uh
kind of time and that's where your
family lives so you got mom and dad you
got Grandma especially back then like
nowadays people are much more mobile
back then like if you were born in
Virginia you were probably gonna die in
Virginia if and your whole family's
probably gonna die and live live and die
in Virginia and same thing with
Connecticut and Maine and Maryland and
everything else so it's like if you are
gonna
gonna defend something it's not just
defending your home it's defending your
entire existence your family your
grandkids your grandparents everything
yeah and especially the prominent
families you know like if you look at
like if you look at like Abraham Lincoln
the difference between them his family
doesn't own plantations they don't
they're not banging it they're moving
you know I mean out of Kentucky they're
just trying to stay out of poverty you
know what I mean they're just looking
for a better way of life I mean that
whole you know what I mean that western
expansion and everybody coming in the
immigrations that's coming into America
and then expanding West you know these
folks are just looking to stay out of
poverty they're looking for a better way
of life uh you know when you're talking
about like Robert E Lee yeah he's not
leaving Virginia man like they own land
in Virginia you know what I mean they're
Orlando and it's not like it's like like
a single wide trailer on a half acre lot
man this dude they're banging it you
know what I mean like Jefferson Davis
he's a plantation owner so yeah you're
you're spot on a lot of those folks that
are in these these these States they're
not leaving the state they might go on a
vacation to go take a trip but they're
coming right back they're not gonna
they're not like us today of very fluid
of moving so Maryland has the warships
in the harbor they have the troops
amassed that they can kind of sense so
they decide all right we're going to
stay with the Union
what about what about Delaware Delaware
they're going to stay with the Union
same sort of intimidation nervousness
like hey we got slaves but we don't
we're not quite sure we want to break
away from
from from the United States of America
yeah and then you got to see where
they're located like you know I mean on
the map you know I mean if they're
they're going to be isolated up there
it's not like they're going to get a lot
of support right you know what I mean
from from a lot of other folks uh coming
in and then you got like a state like
Kentucky that they're just gonna they're
just gonna ride the fence they're gonna
say hey man we're neutral
like we're not we're not picking sides
they're just gonna wait till the end you
know what I mean but and of course then
if you've got like a neutral State well
of course who's where are you going to
go to recruit
Kentucky yeah I mean because they got
folks that are southern sympathizers
that are going to want to go fight for
the Confederacy they're going to want to
fight for that way of life uh you've got
just as many uh you've got folks that
are even on both sides of of of of the
war you got folks from Pennsylvania that
are southern sympathizers that are going
to leave the state of Pennsylvania and
they're going to go south you've got
folks from the south that are going to
come up and they're going to join the
north uh on both sides so you know it
the turmoil in America at that time is
just crazy uh when you kind of think
about like you know leave I mean the
rock of Chickamauga you know what I mean
who he's a Virginian he goes you know he
got guys like that that are fighting for
the Union uh so they're not all Union
Officers are not all Northern descent uh
you do have Southern descent officers
that stay loyal to the union and to the
United States of America which is huge
and you also have people in the north
that were
pro-slavery that we're fighting for the
union go with an accurate statement yeah
uh you know uh when you're looking at it
of some of the general officers uh that
are that are fighting in the north they
basically want like status quo like hey
man let's just let let's just say hey
dude yeah I just I just a false alarm
hey we're not really gonna get rid of
your slavery you can keep keep doing
what you're doing you know what I mean
let's just go back to the way things
were let's just status quo it and we'll
be fine which is you know that's that's
going to be a problem uh especially if
you're a a general officer and you're
kind of like in charge of troops and and
you're in charge of like putting down
this Insurgency of a rebellion you know
what I mean like you're not really on
the same page with the boss
uh which is kind of you flip side to
Jefferson Davis
well pretty much everybody down there
yeah they're all on board with the plan
uh you know what I mean we're going to
create a new country uh we're all art
Lee I mean they're establishing a
government so you know what I mean when
they make him the president and they
succeed it's a new country being formed
uh now in the American Revolutionary War
you know us against England America got
support from Europe
oh yeah and where's Europe now as they
look at what's going on in America they
see this what what now is a looming war
on the horizon where's Europe sitting
yeah and if you look at it you know on a
business perspective so if me and you
own a textile company and we're over in
Europe
where are we getting our cotton from
well we don't need steam engines you
know what I mean like we already got
that uh you know what I mean if you look
look at like at England I mean our the
British royal Navy yeah they are like
Top Notch like these guys are phenomenal
so
of we're going to lean towards the
Confederacy because that's where we're
getting our stuff from you know those
are that's what's supplying us you know
they don't have I mean you know when you
look at the colonies especially with
with England and stuff like that and and
the western expansion of you know the
amount of land mass that's here in the
United States compared to you know
England and France and stuff like that
like it's you know like dude we got like
Texas like okay that's like all of you
all you know what I mean and so there's
a and they're getting it cheap
so you know because they can't grow
their own you know what I mean and if
they do it's going to be more expensive
so they're they're basically Outsourcing
so those folks uh Europe is going to
lean towards you know the Confederacy if
if they become their own country you
know I mean then they have to be
prepared to start setting up trade
agreements and and those certain things
with this new established government uh
that's coming in so uh yeah so when you
look at it on the European theater
they're going to be looking at the
Confederacy because
they need those resources I mean tobacco
and cotton is huge
uh even still to this day I mean you
drive down you know I'm Spotsylvania
Virginia man you just go right down to
Richmond you got Phillip Morris you know
what I mean a huge tobacco now England
had gone through Great Lengths to
shut down slavery throughout the world
at this point in time I mean they had
lost thousands of men mostly mostly
Naval men uh trying to stop slavery
trying to stop slave trade
they must have been in support of the
Union I'm guessing
I think they support the idea when it
comes down to the wallet the wallet uh
you know what I mean like okay this is
this is like really cool that we did it
but you know it's like you know but
that's just them those are the colonies
I mean even when you look at the uh yeah
with the the war of independence I mean
England still existed we didn't get rid
of them you know what I mean they're
kind of like oh you you were fighting
the JV team or whatever to justify well
like when I called it the American
Revolutionary War I can't just call it
in my I'm married to a Brit so she
doesn't even know what the Revolutionary
War is that's not a thing to her like it
didn't like what are you talking about
like for us it's a big deal for them it
was just like oh some some colonists are
causing problems whatever yeah
uh so this is where we end up we end up
we got these you know this this the
lines are now drawn at this point
um there's massive tension
everyone kind of feels what's coming
take us to uh take us to Charleston
Harbor where this thing's gonna kick off
what's that what's that scenario going
on yeah so if you could uh you know
Charleston uh South Carolina yeah I mean
it's a um after they secede uh you know
it's kind of like uh
um so you've got it'd be like in today
to kind of put it in perspective it'd be
like you know California is going to
secede from the Union
well that means like California is going
to get like you're going to get Coronado
you're getting Camp Pendleton you're
getting San Diego Bay you're getting all
that yeah
you know the United States governments
you're not getting any of that you know
what I mean like and you think it's
yours so it's basically the same thing
you've got these Federal forts that you
know what I mean that are that are down
in Charleston and it's not just
Charleston I mean we've got forts you
know what I mean that run all the way
down to down to Key West you know for
Zachary Taylor's all the way down there
uh in Key West so you've got these forts
but there's this one that's sitting and
and it's right there you know federal
government it's it's the federal
government the United States government
and and they're occupying
uh a fort in the Charleston Harbor uh
and they're like you guys need to you
need to surrender and you need to get
you need to get your get your [__] you
need to get out of here man like you
know what I mean this is our stuff now
uh what that uh that surrender
note right so you got this guy uh major
Anderson who's a guy from Kentucky but
his wife's from Georgia and but he's a
union guy
and what I found interesting about this
is this note you can see it's early in
the war this is when people you know you
know all people are naive when it comes
to War I should say most people
especially people that haven't been in
war are naive when it comes to war and
they think that war is going to be
quick and painless and we can predict
what's going to happen and they're all
wrong
but in the beginning of War you know
sometimes it's like oh this is going to
be a cordial event so this guy major
Anderson
gets this note it says uh all proper
facilities will be afforded for the
removal of yourself and command together
with the company arms and property and
all private property to any post in the
United States which you may select the
flag which you have upheld so long and
with so much fortitude under the most
trying circumstances may be saluted by
you on taking it down
and by the way this note is from a guy
named Beauregard
who was one of Anderson's students when
they both went to West Point
but it's like again to me and it's part
of it is the age you know part of it is
the the the gentlemanly aspect of of
life back then and you had this sort of
nice cordial note of saying hey look you
we'll ship you wherever you want to be
shipped you can keep your weapons you
can salute the flag when you bring it
down but you gotta go so you know let's
make it happen
now
Anderson's and you might have to talk me
through this a little bit but Anderson
he
he kind of agrees a little bit thinking
hey if I can't get resupplied
and if I can't uh get any help
then it doesn't really make a ton of
sense for me to fight and and die so
it's like he's starting to consider
surrendering
he doesn't really know that there's
Supply ship outside outside the harbor
that tries to make entry what is it that
the the Star of the West Merchant vessel
unarmed
yeah and you got to imagine like so
you're all the way down on the
Charleston Harbor South Carolina I mean
your boss is all the way up off the
Potomac in Washington DC you know you're
trying like what's the communications
they're gonna mean to being able to
communicate you know there's only a
certain like over on uh Sullivan's
Island
they've got a fort there but it's more
exposed so that's why they go over to uh
over and and hop into the middle of the
bay so they're out at Fort Sumter uh in
the middle of the harbor so now you're
kind of like you're on an island
you know there there's no store there's
no not you know nobody there wants you
there uh you know what I mean so
everybody hates you and you're running
out of out of resupply
uh so yeah they're gonna try to get the
ships and like Winfield Scott and the
guys up up north I mean they know that
like dude we need to get these guys
resupplied uh you know what I mean or we
need to get more bodies down there
but uh you know and I don't know if
you've ever been there uh I have not
yeah I mean it's it's like wow dude I
mean that that Fort you're just sitting
out in the middle uh and you're within
range
you know what I mean of like yeah uh so
it's uh where could I compare it's like
you're on Alcatraz right off of San
Francisco I mean you're just a hop skip
and a jump man right over there well if
you're gonna try to bring in Naval
vessels you know what I mean to run
resupply even if it is unmanned you're
within range on both sides I mean
there's a reason why they had forts
there you know what I mean to defend uh
well now you know what I mean what are
you you never thought of when you
established a fort well what if what if
I gotta defend against my own people
yeah like we didn't think that one
through uh so yeah they can't get to the
communication so kind of at the
beginning I mean when you look at
Anderson one he's struggling with inside
of of the turmoil of himself of one
what's his State going to do he's got
his wife she's from Georgia I mean
you know yeah do I Just Surrender and
you know and and pop smoke uh if I if I
recall
um
Anderson's even thought was if if
Kentucky seceded from the Union that he
was just going to sit this one out
overseas I mean isn't that what we were
kind of talk about like you know what I
mean so he's he's gonna just pop smoke
all together and he's going to go
overseas and just set this one out like
he wants no part of this uh and now he's
sitting in the Charleston Harbor uh and
he's got one of his former students
Beauregard
that's going to send him a note
you know what I mean and it's very
cordial at the time but yeah I mean it'd
be almost like it's anybody else sitting
out there like hey dude if nobody shows
up tomorrow with some resupplies we're
tapping out
because what are we going to do here I
mean this is suicide sitting in the
middle uh
so you know he's he's but then he
finally you know he's realizing that he
can't surrender uh
and you know he shakes off the AIDS that
uh come to get him to surrender and you
know I mean it just uh yeah he's in a
bad spot sitting in the middle of that
Harbor yeah even even the fact that the
guys are there to to offer him surrender
even that's kind of cordial right
um and he ends up shaking their hands
and he says uh if we do not meet again
in this world I hope we may meet in the
better one
and these guys leave and uh
at 4 30 A.M
a 67 year old staunch secessionist named
Edmund Ruffin
pulls the lanyard on his Cannon and the
first shot of the war is fired
and that's the beginning
and we will continue this horrible
Journey on the next
Jocko podcast Civil War Excursion
if you want to support this podcast go
to jockostore.com
go to jockoffuel.com go to originusa.com
go to ashlandfront.com
and go to the omna.com
that's what we've got for now until next
time this is JD and Jocko out